we will now talk about conditional
expectations of one random variable
given another as we will see there will
be nothing new here except for all the
results but given a new notation any PMF
has an Associated expectation and so
conditional pmfs also have associated
expectations which we call conditional
expectations we have already seen them
for the case where we conditioned on an
event a the case where we conditioned on
random variables is exactly the same we
let the event a be the event that Y
takes on a specific value and then we
calculate the expectation using the
relevant conditional probabilities those
that are given by the conditional pmf so
the conditional expectation of x given
that Y takes on a certain value is
defined as the usual expectation except
that we use the conditional
probabilities that apply given that Y
takes on a specific value little Y
recall now the expected value rule for
ordinary expectations and also the
expected value rule for conditional
expectations given an event something
that we have already seen now in PMF
notation the expected value rule takes a
similar form the event a is replaced by
the specific event that Y takes on a
specific value and in that case the
conditional pmf given the event a is
just the conditional pmf given that
random variable Y takes on a specific
value little Y for the case where we
conditioned on events we also developed
a version of the total probability
theorem and the total expectation
theorem we can do the same when we
conditioned on random variables so
suppose that the sample space has been
partitioned into
and disjoint scenarios the total
probability theorem tells us that the
probability of the event the event that
random variable X takes on value little
X can be found by taking the
probabilities of this event under each
one of the possible scenarios and then
weighing those probabilities according
to the probabilities of the different
scenarios now suppose that we are
dealing with a random variable that
takes values in a set consisting of n
elements and let us consider scenarios
AI the eigth scenario is the event that
the random variable Y takes on the eyes
possible value we can apply the total
probability theorem to this situation we
can find the probability that the random
variable X takes on a certain value
little X by considering the probability
of this event happening under each
possible scenario where a scenario is
that Y took on a specific value and then
weigh those probabilities according to
the probabilities of the different
scenarios the story with the total
expectation theorem is similar we know
that an expectation can be found by
taking the conditional expectations
under each one of the scenarios and
weighing them according to the
probabilities of the different scenarios
again let the event that Y takes on a
specific value be a different scenario
and with this correspondence we obtain
the following version of the total
expectation theorem we have a sum of
different terms and each term in the sum
is the probability of a given scenario
times the expected value of X under this
part
stickler scenario at this point I have
to add the comment of a more
mathematical flavor we have been talking
about the partition of the sample space
into finitely many scenarios but if Y
takes on values ended in a discrete but
infinite set for example if Y can take
on any integer value the argument that
we have given is not quite complete
fortunately the total probability
theorem and the total expectation
theorem they both remain true even for
the case where Y ranges over an infinite
set as long as the random variable X has
a well-defined expectation for the total
probability theorem the proof for the
general case can be carried out without
a lot of difficulty just using the
countable additivity axiom however for
the total expectation theorem it takes
some harder mathematical work and this
is beyond our scope but we will just
take this fact for granted that the
total expectation theorem carries over
to the case where we are adding over an
infinite sequence of possible values of
Y in the rest of the course we will
often use the total expectation theorem
including in cases where Y ranges over
an infinite discrete set in fact we will
see that this theorem is an extremely
useful tool that can be used to divide
and conquer complicated models